-Now, you work in the building?
-I do work in the building.
-You have a studio but you do
not have a studio audience?
-No, I don't, but this morning,
I came in
and I see the amazing line
because everyone's here
to come see your show
and I decided to give like a,
"Hey, you know,
anybody from Jersey?"
I'm, like, waving. I'm smiling.
Not one person talks to me.
So I want to say sorry
because you all must be
totally disappointed.
I saw you six hours ago
and you're all like,
and now I'm the guest.
-This is a picture.
You took this picture.
These people are obviously
very excited to see you.
-No, not one. Not one.
Not a single one.
[ Laughter ]
-Well surely, this guy was
excited to see you in person.
-Nope. Not even remotely.
-Really? All right.
[ Laughter ]
-It was like my kids, I'm like,
"Hey, guys, I'm going on
'Seth Meyers.'
Do you want to come?"
And they're like,
"Ugh, to talk news? No."
And my husband is like, "Who
else is going to be there?"
And I said, "Jennifer Garner."
And they're like,
"What? Electra?"
'13 going on 30'? Yes."
And I was like, "Forget it now."
-And now you're not invited.
-No, no.
[ Laughter ]
-We have shown clips
from your show before.
There's a personal favorite
we have.
A lot of times,
you have people on your show,
people who are defending
the Trump administration,
and sometimes they're a little
fast and loose with the facts.
You always seem very quick
with a factual rebuttal.
And here's an example of that
that we enjoy.
-Are we turning around 4% GDP?
When was the last time
you heard 4% GDP growth?
-Five times during
the Obama administration.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean...
Certainly to some degree,
you are aware of
some talking points
that they're going to come.
And was that one where you just
couldn't believe how happy
you were to hear something that
could so quickly be rebutted?
-Well, the thing that's amazing,
these are major business guys,
and they think, "Oh, it's close
enough, I'll just say it,"
and the President loves to say
there's such negative coverage,
"Everyone is out to get me,"
but we're living in
a house of unforced errors.
The President is approaching
having told 5,000 lies.
-Yeah.
-That makes him --
-The most ever, he's very happy
to tell you. Yeah.
-There you go.
[ Laughter ]
That clearly makes him
a habitual liar.
So fact-checking him every day
doesn't mean
it's negative coverage.
The economy -- I mean, that guy
knows the economy.
What President Obama didn't do
was sell the economy well.
President Trump
is a fantastic salesman,
but like a used car salesman,
he's not telling the truth and
it is our job to fact-check him.
So we do.
-When someone like that comes
on, and this happens a lot,
do you think a Trump-supporting
C.E.O. like that,
do you think he actually
believes what he's telling you
or does he just think he's going
to be able to slide it by?
Because, certainly, you would
think he would know
that it happened five times
under the Obama administration.
-Without a doubt,
but I think they think,
"Oh, it's close enough," and in
the world of President Trump,
things are close enough.
Because one thing he has done is
give people confidence.
Consumer confidence is up,
business confidence is up,
because he gets people excited.
The problem is there aren't
the facts to back it up
and they don't think anyone is
actually going to check.
And in this short-term
environment, people don't.
President Trump makes people
feel good.
When they watched him on TV,
on "The Apprentice,"
it was prime time.
They're sitting in their house
on their couch and he's,
"I'm this business guy,
I'm this real-estate guy,
I don't take anything
from anyone."
People built a relationship
and they trusted that.